[Aplausos]
hola
yo vengo un país que se llamaba
venezuela que hay en sur américa al
norte de suramérica todo el norte es mar
caribe al sur selva amazonas macizo
guayanés tenemos cordilleras con picos
nevados tenemos llanos y tenemos mucho
petróleo
desde que llegó el boom del petróleo a
venezuela teníamos
los grandes agua gratis gasolina gratis
hospitales universidades colegios
y la gente lo aprovecho por muchos años
en el 99 llegó un nuevo gobierno dijo
ser socialista dijo bueno vamos a
cambiar todo la verdad es que no
cambiaron nada
sigue siendo lo mismo lo que pasa es que
lo que teníamos en infraestructura y
universidades
ahorita está prácticamente destruido las
pocas tierras que se trabajaban porque
nunca fuimos un país importador
fueron expropiadas y se las dieron a
militares los cuales no supieron
manejarlas y las quebraron pero el
problema es que ahora el gobierno está
intentando
darle a la gente de comer lo que está
pasando ahora es que la gente más
vulnerable
está dependiendo de que el gobierno los
alimente una caja de comida que le
entregan al mes muchas veces no llega y
cuando no llega protestan
para nuestros inmigrantes que llegaron a
venezuela
por dar dos ejemplos los portugueses
me imagino que les suena ridículo que no
puedan comer si no les llega una caja de
comida
ellos venían de una cultura que no era
rentista como la nuestra y eso gente que
sabe trabajar la tierra venezuela tú
tienes una semilla y algo van a hacer
gente en la ciudad los portugueses en
caracas trajeron su cultura algunos
tienen grandes mercados otros tienen sus
huertos algunos se les expropiaron
también hay otro ejemplo de una colonia
que está situada las montañas cerca de
caracas que es una colonia alemana
y ellos todo lo hacer ellos
hasta la cerveza
ya que llegamos a este punto en el que
hay 4 millones de personas que dependen
de un gobierno que en verdad los está
humillando
para comer no podemos dejar que los
humillan
con la comida porque lo que va a pasar
es que las próximas generaciones van a
estar mal alimentadas
y no van a servir para nada
y la pregunta es quién sufrió más la
crisis ellos o nosotros
las